okay
thank you everyone for for coming so
um yeah my name is Jeremy and uh I'm uh
I'm a college Jupiter developer and over
the past uh I think two years already
we've been working on a new distribution
of Jupiter called Jupiter light
and this is what we'll be talking about
today
um and uh the goal will be to show you
how you can use tripurite and how you
can create your own PDI deployment so
you can create applications and make
them available to to your users so we're
gonna going to start with uh a few
slides first and then we're going to
jump uh into the the workshop so
uh if you were here last year at the
conference uh there was a talk about
Jupiter light that was more of
a presentation but the new tool
so I invite you to check it out it's on
YouTube and there you we cover a bit
more like
the differences and also the history of
of crypto Lite
so you might wonder like
in Jupiter Riders the word light like
how how is it different compared to a
normal Jupiter so
the main difference if you use it from
for example from a GitHub Pages
deployment is that it's very very fast
to uh to start so you can just get
through it very quickly get to the
interface very quickly
and that is because uh
jupiterrite
departments can be created using a Egypt
right CRI tool which is
kind of like a static site generator so
if you have used the Jackal before a
ruby based static site generator
you can think of drip to write as
something similar
so it's just like you have a command
variable in your terminal you run it and
it generates
HTML CSS and JavaScript files and also
we will see it later your content for
example notebooks
and what that means is if it's just
static web static files you don't need a
application server anymore to serve your
your Jupiter and an application server
is
uh usually in Jupiter world is based on
python so you need first a server and
then python which can be sometimes
tricky to get
you don't need a command line
for using the tool for building the tool
we will see we still need to go to the
terminal
and uh probably one of the best thing
about this is that your users they
really don't need to deal with
installing python locally or installing
other packages located especially on
Windows Mac OS Linux all of these
different platforms can sometimes create
frictions when you want to for example
do a tutorial or
or teach something via entrepr
so
again like the main advantage of
jupiterrite is the fact that it's very
easy to deploy
so there is documentation there if you
want to check it out
[Music]
and what that means is that in practice
you only need HTTP server like something
very simple if you used the http.server
module in Python we will see also that
later you can just start it with python
minus M http.server and the new server
files are like this
um okay before I continue this is
interactive as the name suggests so if
you have any question uh don't hesitate
and we can we can take them as we as we
go no problem
so
um where can you host crypto Lite uh
pretty much anywhere where you can get a
HTTP server uh like a simple GP server
so GitHub pages is a very good candidate
we have many examples running on GitHub
pages and the same for gitlab gitlab
pages
read the docs
even binder if you want and also more
like those platforms that you see more
in the front-end World usually versatile
or netlify also works there
and of course there are many many others
so
if you write is not that new it's not
like a crazy new thing but it's more
like building on top of everything that
already exists so
the interface is based on your credit
components which means that
they were reassembled together to
produce something something else so
there are a few functionalities in
Jupiter that are not available in
Jupiter Lite for example a debugger
maybe that will be your case later
but the idea is you take those building
blocks you put them together and you
create this new application and the
important thing is that
the front end so you do the UI that you
get when you use drip to write is still
the same and it communicates the same
with the kernels and we will see that
the main difference with the counters is
that they don't run on a server because
there is no application server anymore
but they're running a browser and they
still communicate with the front-end
using the jupyter protocol
and the Jupiter protocol is really this
Central piece like in the set at the
center of Jupiter that you will find
everywhere but you never see it as a
user but it's really this this thing
that makes uh compatibility between
notebooks interfaces and also kernels as
possible it's the standard pretty much
protocol standard
the app you can find you can use
um visualization libraries you're
familiar with matplotlib because Broad
and so on and
we chipped right so as we said like the
kernels run in a browser and that is
made possible using a
a browser technology called webassembly
so webassembly is there
the fourth standard in in a web browser
world so you have HTML JavaScript CSS
and now we have webassembly uh
webassembly
it allows you to take a program written
in another language for example CC plus
plus or even rest and compile it to
something that the web browser can
understand and
the good thing is python the default
implementation of python is called C
Python and C python is implemented in C
and C can be compared to webassembly so
that's what people have been doing
especially with our private eye project
they were the ones kind of
starting all of this
so that means that now we can have
python running in a web browser thanks
to this
so when it comes to interactive
Computing which is what we'll be talking
about with crypto Lite
we have two python kernels so one is
called Pi died and the other one is
called Swiss python so they take
different approaches we see that later
but it's pretty much the same in the end
it's just taking Python and combining it
to webassembly so you can use it in in a
browser and the books report
like we said before like the
visualizations library uh might probably
by probably just brought here and more
so one thing we've been starting to see
with this and
this is something that potentially can
interest you uh at the end if one if you
when we finish to
the tutorial is that once you have a
Jupiter light deployment out there you
can pretty much embed it very easily in
other places in other websites so here
is just an example of how you could
embed a small python console in your
blog and this is using a component in
Jupiter that is already there it's been
there for many years it's the code
console it just gives you a console
that's it but you can already do quite a
bit of things with this
but one of the major adapters is the
numpy.org website so if you go there you
will find something that looks the same
and you can play around with them by in
a browser so that's pretty convenient
to try things out
and it's the same for Senpai now they
also adopted it and we've seen that like
across many other popular
packages in the body test tag so
everybody is starting to look it's like
oh I want the same so they decide to to
do the same so it's a
it's been uh growing a bit fast like
this
um
another use case is the the actual
Jupiter website itself
so it used to be using a service called
mybinder I don't know if you know this
this is like a text to your repo
I looks at the differences in the
requirements of text or environmental
hammer
and creates a Docker image and then it
pushes it to a cloud and then it starts
a server like a normal Jupiter server
and then you get access to it via your
browser so that's really great if you
want
to be able to reproduce stuff using this
but we were also using it on a jupy
website to just to demo the
Jupiter lab entrepreneur notebook
interfaces and now
um
this has been switched to using crypto
Lite and that had a lot when it comes
through
compute resources because at some point
maybe last year or so the binder project
had some issues with funding
I think it's okay now but they were
looking in a way to cut the cost and
we are we deployed this this thing very
quickly on GitHub pages and really
helped to reduce okay I don't have it
here but it was something like 30 or so
in terms of of traffic and also
resources used
on uh on the cloud
so yeah here the trade-off is you can
you you exchange compute resources for
static assets so arguably your bandwidth
is going to increase a little bit more
because you have more files to send to
your users over the wire so yeah
another way you can embed it is if you
have a docs so that's also similar to
what we saw before with many packages
have started to
use tripolite to embed a notebook or
code console in their docs so that's
again like the docs is where you you go
find information for how you use a
package and it's great if you can
actually try it there directly
so main advantages are that it's easy to
deploy it's just a bunch of static files
it's simply for users they don't need to
install python or any other packages
locally for educational use cases
especially when you want to do one only
like very simple things or
or cover the basics of python this is a
very great and um
and also one last thing is
once you have your website with
everything all of the assets it's very
easy to just take it and put it
somewhere like archive it or put it on a
USB stick and you can think of it as a
time capsule so
the good thing about the web is that
it's all governed by by standards so
it's very unlikely that JavaScript HTML
and CSS and webassembly are going away
anytime soon so if you have some
research and you want to kind of make
sure that it's going to work again in
maybe 10 or 15 years then once you have
this and
your set of static files you can pretty
much just say okay it's done and then
you can just package it or put somewhere
around it maybe open it later and it
will work just like websites
created 10 years ago they still work
today so that's uh that's a really big
big strength
but uh it also has some limitations so
you know it's always a game of
trade-offs in the end so you can't do
very heavy workloads so you won't be
able to uh just use gigabytes of data
because your browser is going to crash
before
um you can't use gpus yet maybe it would
be possible in the future
um let's see
one thing about packages is that many
packages are also not available
I don't know we don't even know if they
will be at some point if it makes even
sense to have them on on a browser
so in the end you work with um some kind
of subset of python in a browser you
also don't have multi-processing right
now I think it's going to be the case
later but as of today it's not easy
easily possible to to enable that or
even just raw sockets
and
um since your execution
um
environment is now in a browser you need
to bring that to your browser from
somewhere so you have increased
data uh
over the wire over the network so if you
look at the uh like in your web browser
you can access to developer tools you
will see that more data is uh is
transferred over the wire so that's the
that's the trade-off
fortunately the browsers are able to to
cache data quite aggressively sometimes
but uh
that can already help to avoid
downloading the same files over and over
again
so in this tutorial
um I'm going to show how you can make
your own so pretty much you can just
host it yourself on your GitHub or
anywhere else if you want and there is a
demo repository I think we're going to
start without just just to be sure and
then we're going to check how you can
add files notebooks
extensions other packages
how you can customize how you can build
a small application using jupy widgets
and how you can export all of that as a
static dashboard so yeah
and if you want to go to this URL so
that is a
the script will be following
on on read the docs and I think I posted
it on Discord already so you can also
find it there
yeah it should be good
yeah so if you have any questions uh
on the intro slides yes
yeah so we will see it later but maybe I
can already give some um
some uh some answers here maybe I will
repeat the question so the question was
how do you know if a package is
available right for the browser
um
so
so in this tutorial we're going to use
uh remember when I said there were two
python kernels right now one copied iron
and one called Zeus python we're going
to go with Swiss python
um which is very similar in the end um
but the difference is that the cruise
python reuses the whole contact Forge
infrastructure so if you are familiar
who here is familiar with conda
okay that's good yeah maybe half of the
room
um so contact Forge is a decentralized
way of working with packages and even
packaging python packages so it's not
like just a couple of people who handle
the thousands of packages coming from
everywhere it's more like each
maintainer has the responsibility for
their own package um there is a lot of
CI going on a lot of bots and that makes
makes it much easier to work with this
and publish packages to make a contact
Channel called Corner Forge
and for we see it again later but uh
just to give you an idea um so if you
want to see if a package is available
you have to check in two places
so if you would be just using a normal
Jupiter you could just check on condo
four drop by pi but here since we are in
a browser not everything is available so
the first thing you can check is for
example let's say iPad widgets so by
widgets is this thing that lets you
create a
controls so
I use this prefix.f website because it's
very very easy on the very Sleek but you
can also go to anaconda.org and also
search from there so we see that it's
there so it's fine and it's so no Arch
package so it means it's not tied to a
specific architecture so that means that
this one can be installed whether it
will be working or not is another story
because it might depend on other
packages which are maybe not you know
maybe they don't work in a browser or
not so
so it's still hard to know uh whether
something is available on the other
place we need to look into is
this channel called M script and Forge
and M script and Forge is it's like
contact Forge but for
packages that need to be compiled in
some way before so if you have numpy for
example if you want to use numpy you
will find it here
it's here it's available because it has
C extensions and they need to be
compiled to webassembly and for that we
use a tool called Ms Krypton
if you wear the
web assembly presentation on Monday I
think uh Antonio talked a little bit
about scripting
so without going too much into the
details it's a bit like GCC you know but
for for the web and also for servers but
in our case it's not it's not really the
topic but you could use webassembly
somewhere else and then just in the
browser
but yeah let's forget that for now
so yeah so you have to check there and
then uh also also on the other
of the page but if you are using
paradite you can also use the micropip
helper which is in paradite maybe we'll
have time to to check that as well at
the end
and you can try to install and see if it
works and then import and if it does
then we are good but since there is an
issue about this in the GPS we Pro I
think we will put it at some point a
small tool to make that much easier
because otherwise people maybe don't
know where to where to look
okay any other questions yes
[Music]
is it shared between some of them okay
yeah we will uh yeah we will see all of
this so the first question is how is it
different compared to Google collab uh
so Google collab uh lets you use
notebooks in a browser as well but
um in on the back end they still use a
jupy server or something similar I'm not
exactly sure if they use the the road
triple server from the open source
project but it has to be something like
this and they also use a kernel on the
server and they give you access to gpus
so they are like you know it's a bit
more heavy but you have more resources
and it's also something you cannot host
yourself so if you wanted to use it also
offline with drip right you can but with
a
collab is going to be more tricky and
about the content management so
for now you can create a Jupiter light
deployment with content already so it's
already available to your users it will
just be distributed as a static file
and then when they open the interface
when they open the notebook
when they edit it it will be saved in
the browser storage
yeah so it's there is a component in a
browser called indexeddb it's like a
database in your in your browser and
Jupiter uses this to store the notebooks
and make sure they are not lost but all
of this is scoped by domain name so uh
if you work if you have your light
department on this domain
It's a combination of domain Imports
your notebook is will be available only
if you access other Egypt rights hosted
under the same domain and that is for
security reasons right for inspecting
the browser
but if you switch domains then they
won't see the same notebooks and from
the interface you can also download the
notebooks if you want
but again like since jupiterrite is
based on GP lab and Jupiter lab is a set
of extensions you can also create your
own extension and store the content
somewhere else so it's modular enough it
requires a bit of work it requires web
development skills because you need to
integrate that with a typescript
extension but uh I think some people
have already done that they they want to
store that somewhere else like on the uh
on S3 for example or another place in a
on a cloud so they dissociate the
content from the actual interface
on the site yeah
all right so
let's see
yeah I think we have an hour or so so
that should be enough
um so what we're going to try to do
let's see if I'm going to uh to the end
or not um
is to build something like this so this
is trip to light it's running on guitar
Pages this is a demo I did before and we
use widgets we paste the link a list of
URLs with a GPS coordinates I'm going to
show a map pretty much just the app
where you can show your pictures and
then you click on that
and then you can just
hit the done with the save button it's
going to download the HTML
for the map and then you can open it
and sit so you can see that as an app
for your users who want for example to
just fiddle with maps but you can
imagine anything else so if you have any
other thing you would like to do on a
work with RV free you just need to swap
the notebook with your own and of course
fix the dependencies if you use all the
dependencies so that you are free to do
that if you want
so
we're going to pick some parts of the
existing docks so the docs and Jupiter
light already cover how you can get
started so there is a getting starting
section here you can use something that
is already available or you can deploy
your own on GitHub pages and then the
thing we saw with the wrapper on the
website and so on and then you have more
focused topics or Focus guides on
different topics so here how you can
configure it add content and so on so
this page is pretty much just a kind of
a summary or all of this and we're going
to do it live
so we see like all of the steps and what
it means
Okay so
so you have to we have two way to
proceed here and it's going to be a
matter of preferences so I'm going to
first show how we can use the demo
template which is the kind of
recommended way if you want to make
something on guitar pages but then we're
going to continue with the actual
Jupiter light CLI like I mentioned
before uh just to show you what happens
when you use it because in the end this
is what is used on the GitHub template
anyway uh so it's also good to know how
the CRI works so you you can more easily
debug it in case you have issues so so
if you go to this
repo here this is called excuse python
demo
does everybody have a GitHub account
then it's good
um
if you don't don't worry if you want to
do it later you can also just follow the
tutorial later
should be fine
this is focus python kernel there's
another one for the paradise corner but
we're going to use this one today so if
you go here use this template create a
new
repository this is going to create a new
repository under your account or you can
choose an org if you are also part of an
orc
Let's see we can do a back on the
um
Jupiter light
tutorial
we leave it as public because otherwise
deeper into GitHub pages is going to be
more difficult unless you have a pro
subscription I think
and that's it so you can create click on
create afterwards
so it generates the repo
it's pretty much just copying the files
that's it one thing you need to do and
that is also mentioned in the get
started on the docs go to the settings
and then pages
and here you need to select GitHub
actions so it's going to use GitHub
actions to deploy to GitHub pages
before it was
to deploy together Pages you had to set
up a GH Branch GH Pages Branch but this
is kind of
the old way of doing that now they are
switching to using GitHub actions
which is still better for now but maybe
it will become the default at some point
this is what the template uses
yeah so if you go back to uh your repo
once you've generated
uh you can see that there are first
there is the CI running
CI is to continuous integration it's
going to run some scripts to run the
jupiterrite command so let's check that
first just so you know where it is
so here there is a GitHub action a
GitHub workflow to deploy the crypto
Lite website and it does a bunch of
setup and that's a
that's uh implementer and details and
then here
it calls Georgia right CRI by doing
which the right build but don't worry
about this we'll see uh see that later
and then when it's done
it pushes to the GitHub Pages
environment here using the GitHub
actions
foreign
is just what it does for deploying so
it's just a bunch of of commands to run
and GitHub actions to use so
while it's doing its thing
you can look at the rest of the repo
so the content folder is where you can
put your content and the demo here is
the thing I showed you on the video just
before we get that get back to that
afterwards okay now this is not the one
but never mind this is the just the
Timor notebook
and then you have environment and build
environment so if you're familiar with
contact Forge you will recognize those
build environment is
your as the name suggests the
differences for building a website so we
have to keep in mind that there are
two environments
one for building a website and one for
executing code in a browser okay
so one for building the website is this
one
and we see that we have the differences
on the editorite CLI
and the other one for running the code
is this one and this is where we see we
have a different C on the iPad widget
for example yeah
okay
so let's go back here here we have the
green checkbox
that means
what you can do actually go here
and click on use your GitHub
Pages website
save so now it's going to be available
here
and you open it on a new tab
I don't know why it's not this GPS but
okay so it's using my
domain name here because I mapped it two
GitHub pages but for you maybe it would
just be something on github.io which is
also fine
yeah
yep sure so the last step was how do you
get from this report to the actual
GitHub Pages deployment so the GitHub UI
provides the governor way to do it if
you
click on this gear here
then there is this checkbox
and it's going to generate it if it's
not there for some reasons you can also
easily construct it yourself so
is going to be your username
and then Dot github.io
and then slash
the name of the repo
and redirects to the jupiterrite and
there you go just a couple of seconds
okay minutes for building the website
and and you have it there so yeah
so that's how you can get started
um
next we will see how to use the Jupiter
light web CRI it's going to require a
couple of require differences on your
machine so in case it doesn't work for
you or
you just don't want to do it or whatever
you can also use
the repo directly so I can to show
let's say you want to add the dependency
here let's say you want to add numpy
right so we go to the environment.jamor
which is the one for the browser
you go here and I will recommend
creating a branch
for example add dependency
and then here you can say add
numpy
and then you propose change it's going
to
commit your change
in a new branch and then GitHub
automatically asks you if you want to
create a request so you can do this you
can say yes and create a pull request
so that's a way for you to work on your
Jupiter light website without even
touching the terminal however it's going
to be a bit you have to be patient
because you need to wait for the CI to
build the thing for you so you can see
it here the checks are available here
and once this check is done it produces
an artifact on GitHub pages on GitHub
actions that you can download and double
check yeah so that's a good way to to
work with this
unfortunately there is not a way for now
to get to get Gita Pages previews
automatically from pull requests so that
would be great unfortunately GitHub
Pages only works on specific branches
but maybe at some point they would add
something like this and unfortunately
right that would be super useful because
then you could just work from your repo
and get previews
uh without doing anything locally
there are already ways to do it if you
use read the docs or verser they give
you like live previews or even netify
and I produce URLs that you can double
check before merging your changes so
so why it's doing this we're going to
uh to jump into into the CRI so I will
um I will go a bit more in depth here
just so you get an idea of how it works
under the hood so if you want to use the
CLI there is also a guide on the docs
later if you want to get back to that at
some point so for that you need a
terminal and uh in our case we'll be
using a package management tool called
mamba or to be more precise micro member
to confuse you even more Mumbai is a bit
like um it's like conda pretty much it's
a drop-in replacement it was created to
speed uh conda up speed things up when
it comes to solving the environment and
now conda is even using parts of member
in their in their conda CRI tool
so with micro mobile it's easy because
it's just a binary so you can just
install it like this curve bash and then
you get it
yeah you can also do it with python like
this if you want however
for the excuse python kernel since it's
using contact Forge to fetch the
packages you will still need to have
contact at some point so you still need
to install conda
but we can see later how to use the
pilot package which is not
which doesn't require using a conda
so I'm going to do this
now so it doesn't take too much time
yes it's that's probably because you
choose to create a private
repo right
yeah
yeah so the question is uh
need to update to GitHub Pro to the
program guitar Pages uh yes if you have
a private repo know if you have a public
repo
okay so here I
so if you don't have Micro mobile I
still recommend it to you to check it
out there are blocks here it's linked
um but we're going to do
to create
[Music]
um
in a virtual environment
to install our build dependencies so
that would be jupiterrite and other
build dependencies
and again this is separate from the
execution environment which is in the
browser and it's going to be managed
separately so to keep things
well
separated
okay so number activate
code already
tutorial
now if you remember this now you get a
bunch of
other dependencies so if we go back to
to the next step
yeah I know this one is uh from uh from
this right yeah it's like like I
mentioned in the beginning it's just a
summary of of the others and I'm just
linking you to the docs in case you want
to go more in the in details uh
afterwards
um but for now we're just going to
follow this the script
yeah
so I'm going to to do this one in the
meantime
so here we installed the CLI and also
another differences that will be useful
for indexing the content so it's
available on the site
so we use a member to install you can
also use conda
okay and you can double check that Egypt
right
CLI
is available yes
which file
yes yeah you can use that yeah yeah yeah
absolutely it's a good practice actually
to do this like this to install it in a
in a environment here I'm just doing it
step by step to go through all of the
differences we need but you're right
it's better to
to keep it in a
in this file here yeah you just put it
actually all of them are already here
the one I'm going to install yeah
but once you have in your official
environment if you don't want to use
Mumbai you could also use pip it's
available on on pipe Pi you just need to
install it like this with the right core
and then the brackets with lab or you
can install triple lab on the side just
because it's needed for indexing the
content and also a bunch of other
extensions we will see later yeah
okay so once you have this you can do a
Jupiter light in it
and
if you do LS okay let's do this you get
two files one is a hidden file it's for
storing the previously executed steps so
you don't need to care too much about
this and the output is the default name
of the output folder and this is pretty
much that's it that's your that's your
site everything is in the output folder
so let's see if we do
yeah if you do a tree you see that you
have notebooks HTML files CSS files
javascripts of course
um and a bunch of other things so yeah
once you have this
um
you can actually just serve it so you
can use the trip to Lite serve command
or you can use also the python minus M
http.server like we talked about before
a bit bigger yeah so let's just use this
for for Simplicity
and then you go to localhost
okay I think it's my cache yep
put that back into light
so I see that I have a notebook from a
previous
try because it's still under the same
localhost domain but yeah let me see
first
no yeah okay so cash issues that was a
good demonstration of cash issues so
um
since I already did that before my
machine under the local roast 8000 Port
my browser remembered that I had already
static assets and it was showing a
kernel on the interface which shouldn't
be the case right now because we haven't
added one
so here we are currently at this step
let's see where you get only
something very
very dry there is nothing really you can
do that much just the bear application
where we're going to to change this so
now you need a kernel so we're going to
use success python kernel you can use
pip to install it unfortunately I don't
think it's available on contact force
right now but it will be eventually
um
yeah so once you have the Jupiter light
shoes python kernel
the thing you need to do is to build the
website again so it's always this um
this step is to always record a bit like
uh
when you build your website with Checker
you do checker build they also have a a
serve command I think which rebuilds
automatically
but that's again that's only when you
want to create your your assets uh once
you they are distributed on guitar Pages
you don't need to deal with this anymore
yeah
so let's do it
so we see that it triggered some
remember I think their analysis
because we need to pack the environment
they will be running in a browser
that is done using micro member we could
also be done using mobile contact
and
we haven't added any
any dependencies yet but we'll see how
to do it after but it still creates
defines that the python runtime would be
needed
in the browser so we already have the
server running here so we can go back
to this
yeah and now we have a kernel uh showing
up in the interface
so you can click on that
and like we saw in the beginning in the
sound transition
it can take a little while to to uh to
Startup so the icon here was uh
had a different state for a while I
don't know if you noticed
and that is because you need to start
python in a browser and also download a
lot of the files can take a while uh
still but then once it's there it's
available
you can
can do some
whatever you want however
oh it's already there okay never mind
however if you want to
use different packages they might not be
there yet and we're going to add them uh
right after
okay so first we're going to add some
content so working with notebooks is
important with a Jupiter deployment so
if you don't have one
around the notebook you can use your own
otherwise there is the Spy shoots repo
which is quite a
quite interesting lots of
of examples of how to use notebooks so
we're going to download it
and I'm going to put it in
in
notebooks folder
and Save
we are here
still
um
you got some someone asking online okay
is this the right tool to create an
inter interactive python app when all
the coding is hidden
we see at the end at the end you can
create a static dashboard so you can use
notebooks indeed to do this otherwise
you can use Paradise directly or even Pi
script it's also a tool to make python
apps without showing the code
but at the end
yeah should be enough time I will see
how you can actually go from The
Notebook from a static dashboard
Okay so
maybe let's spin things up a bit
um so now we have a notebooks folder
here Wi-Fi list I have a notebook in
there
what you need to do is rebuild again
build but this time
specifying the contents
so that means
so there is no application server
remember so if your browser asks for a
file how can we know if there is a file
or not so drip the right at build time
in Texas the files and makes makes them
a variable via a metadata file so you
can know be aware of what files you have
available so this is part of the build
step
specify the notebooks
I'm going to refresh the page and now I
have this Sudoku notebook available here
this one is living in my browser
if so if you do that you won't have it
unless you create the same name but uh
it's in index DB like we here we saw
before but now you can open this one and
we can work with it yeah
Okay so
uh dried can we use uh
almost I would say most of the Jupiter
lab extensions some of them will not
work uh because they need more
components or maybe they are not suited
for the browser but simple ones uh or
maybe more advanced ones can also work
so you can see how we can add some of
them so there is this execute time
extension that you can add to your
to your site so as again you install it
in your environment or you add it to
your build environment.yamor file
yeah it's here
so that's a Jupiter lab extension but
Jupiter light is able to reuse the same
extension I just need to build it again
we're going to keep the contents flag
for now so we don't lose our
our notebook we added earlier
okay
by the way for those using the
the GitHub
directly GitHub interface so all of this
you can do
by going
to your branch
and you can edit the environment if it's
a python dependency you add it on the
PIP if it's a contact under the
dependency here
and once you have a
checkbox here
you can actually check your
build website from the summary it's a
bit complicated but yeah that's the
GitHub actions UI and then you click
here it's going to download
the turbo see it's quite heavy because
it has our dependencies
and then you can run your server your
HTTP server from from there
my question are you planning to support
or are you supporting bokeh
yeah I think I'm not sure if bookie
works but panel does I'm not sure if
I would say it should
it should work because if I remember
correctly they have a version based on
iPad widgets here by widgets hours so uh
available in Jupiter rights so I would
say it should and if it's not then maybe
it's just a matter of time yeah
I buy widgets yeah
okay so back to our
to our site
yeah so now we have the extension and
you can see there is this new new thing
here and that is provided by the third
party extension that's not in part of
jupy by default it's something we added
extra and that's the one
crucial point about the whole triple
ecosystem is you can configure it
very deeply if you want and there are
many extensions like these ones
and this one gives you like the time it
took to execute yourself so it could be
useful to have on your website
um
so one other thing we can check is how
to add a theme so here you have by
default the Dark theme and a light theme
but you can also install one and I think
this is this one here you can install
one that is a third-party theme let's
say
the Knight theme for example which is
quite cool
okay this is because I didn't save The
Notebook
might take a while for the browser to
pick up the changes
you're right
yeah that was good uh actually you just
need to rebuild it's to forget
yeah so when you build um
a site it copies the the extension files
which are also just JavaScript files
static files to the build directory in
our case the output it's okay so we're
going a bit in depth here you don't need
to exactly know of this but uh in the
end they end up here so in the under the
extensions folder you see that there is
the night theme now
let's refresh
yeah
and now we have the new theme okay
um
there are just a lot of things you can
add to websites so we're going to see
another one is how you can add a new
display language so this is all English
right now but let's say you want to add
a French support to your
to your Jupiter light
which is quite useful actually because
we have there are some people using
jupiterrite in France for education and
they've been using uh the translation
package that we're installing right now
to have everything in French so yeah
let's pick up the question maybe while
it's building no there's no question
okay that's good
um where you got a technical question
although I think you mentioned about
already when trying to rebuild my page
it feels saying I need mamba or conda is
it not possible to run Jupiter light
with virtual environment yes
um so that's with someone from remote
maybe they can check the report term of
this page here the tutorial there is
extra and you can use the biodight
kernel instead so you can skip the
excuse python which requires Mamba to
build your environment and use paradite
instead and then I will refer to the
docs directly the obtzer to follow
remotely I think then you can use
paradite to install packages it would be
a bit different right now so in future
we hope there will be some kind of
conversions I think is going to happen
at some point between the two kernels
but for now this is how things are so
it's good also to State them just so
that you know about that but I will
recommend using this uh if you don't
want to deal with
um
number locally or use the repo directly
like this and then it's available on the
GitHub actions here
so let's go back
here and
yeah in settings now you have
an option to switch to French
so this is what students see sometimes
you know okay there is a
cash issue yeah
uh yeah in France when they use dried
for their for the introductory
introductory class on How to Learn
Python for example
so
let's go back to English
uh
what yeah now we go back to
here to the next step is
how you can install extra packages so
here there is a little note reminding
you that we're using indexus python
learner which is based on contact Forge
pretty much an app script approach
so it means that you have an
environmental yamor file located so here
I'm going to show you
um how to do that
so for now there is no environmental
Jammer file
online machine because they started from
scratch
if you started from the repo there
should be should be a one already in the
files here
so I'm going to create one
you see that we specify two channels
that might be a bit unfamiliar to you
they are the ones
especially the amp screen 4 is the one
listing the packages that were built for
webassembly so that we can reuse them in
the environment that will be running in
a browser yeah I probably just in
foreign
packages so they can be used with items
written Force but later if we add more
let's say packages like pandas on numpy
I'm starting four will be needed so
this and then
another build
so I'm going to scroll up again and you
see that in the build
the build step trite is now installing
volume which is dependency and also iPad
widgets so for me it says it's cache
because I already did it before
otherwise it would be fetching it from
from the internet
that's it
and
again I refresh
let's create a new notebook yeah this is
the indicator I mentioned before like
usually on normal GPU it's much faster
uh here in the browser it takes a bit
more time
that works
okay maybe it's not
uh browser
I think there is even a code we can copy
paste just this
okay so yeah you saw before that
sometimes you can have some errors
um this is likely due to browser caching
the previous assets so that
we asked portfolio but it's not there
yet I just need to be patient and
refresh again afterwards question
yes
where
should actually configure it to include
this yes it would be environmental
chamber
uh did you start from the
the excuse python
template or the demo template
the demo is based on paradite
yeah sorry for confusing you but this is
the how it is right now yeah
um yeah doc Swiss python demo is uh is
the one with the environmental chamber
yes yeah so if you want to restart with
the other one that will be easier
otherwise
otherwise you think you can just uh yeah
continue from your repo and add also the
jupiterrite excuse python
dependency
in your build environment but I think it
would be simple to start again
with GitHub generate a new project yeah
yes
uh in this at the top level
yeah where you will be running your uh
your build command so
yes yeah but you know that all of this
this is just a default this is also
configurable
um so you could for example output the
folder somewhere else and I'll also use
an environmental Yammer file that is not
named environmental Yammer but you need
to specify extra
I parameter I don't want to confuse you
too much about this right now but it's
possible if you are if you want
okay so we have our packages available
with the versions here and um
and like we saw already before so maybe
we're going to go a bit quicker on that
now
is that M Street and Forge is where
packages are pulled from so they work in
a browser compared to webassembly
um and the main difference compared to
piadite
is that paradise as of today they still
bundle a whole distribution together so
they are like
a distribution with a numpy pandas and a
bunch of other
scientific packages all together
but it becomes a bit tricky to to use if
you want to have more control on the
versions you want to use of the packages
and also which ones you want so maybe
you don't want Senpai in your deployment
but unfortunately with pilot it's there
by default so
um it's two different approaches but
there's been some some work to make the
two kind of talk to each other at some
point so at some point we'll probably
see Paradise being able to reuse and
certain Forge packages as well so it's a
bit easier to compose uh environment
like you would be doing on a normal
Jupiter
this note is about how to find if a
package is available that's what we
discussed today a bit earlier
and if you want to know more about it
there's always to talk so
yeah
there is also this configuration file so
lots of config files but this one lets
you put your CRI parameter like we
contents for example here if we don't
want to repeat this all the time or if
you want to have a central place where
you have or your configuration set for
your jupiterrite website you can also
create this file and then
uh place the content here so there is
the document on the like the structure
of this file and where to put the
arguments it can be very useful once you
start to have something more customized
than what we're going to do so we don't
have to
have a huge CRI uh common 97 with a lot
of parameters so once you have a file
there and you run the build the build
step would pick up the file and do the
same as we saw before
there is also this file the Jupiter oh
sorry there is a typo it's uh not
underscore it's hyphen so I'm going to
to show you that so this is for
runtime
runtime configuration so the other one
was for build time and this one is for
runtime so when you reload the page
pretty much here we're going to just
change the name of the
of the of the app
which you need to build because the
build is going to take that file and put
it in the output directory
let me do a check time
okay
yeah you see that there is a drip
Delight Json file here
if we go back to our
test demo we see it here is written
about Jupiter light but
now that if we refresh
now it says drip dry tutorial because
that's the
the name we gave in app name there are a
bunch of other things you can configure
there
including enabling real-time
collaboration so
there is report
that is a bit buggy right now for RTC in
jupiterrite it's using webrtc so you
have
you can imagine having people
collaborate on notebooks deployed on
static HTTP server
without setting up a service you still
need a way for them to talk to each
other over webrtc but this is possible
but uh yeah if you want to try be
careful because it's still a bit
experimental and it's not working really
well
all right so
I think we're going to stop here for the
actual Jupiter light interface you know
like the Jupiter lab you should also
know that if you are more of a classic
notebook user jupiterrite includes a
notebook view like a notebook
application similar to
the classic notebook except that it's
not the classic notebook so
if you are curious about this you should
come to my second talk right after that
will be in another room uh we'll be
talking about the future of the triple
notebook and pretty much what you see
here but some people like that interface
especially for teaching because it's
just a notebook and
yeah you don't have any distractions and
people just like to work with that so
it's also possible it's including
egyptolite and this is based also
injector app components
okay so now we're going to talk about
how to create static dashboards from
your notebooks so
the video I saw like uh show you that um
these small applications we wanted to
make so now we're going to to cover that
so who here has used the voila already
before
okay it's not that much uh it's just
maybe
quarter maybe not even so water is like
it's a Jupiter project as well it
doesn't have Jupiter in the name but
it's still a Jupiter project
and
the main idea with water is let me see
if there is a screencast I think there
is one here yes it's just loading do you
take your notebook let's say you worked
on analysis on app or something like
that and you want to you really don't
want to rewrite it in another language
or in python or you don't have time for
that let's say
um
with water you just run the voila CRI
and it starts the triple server and it's
going to show you this
your app like there you go
in a new tab in a browser tab
with just the output so that's what
there was a question earlier about this
like how do you do you do this well I'll
let you do that yeah but voila itself
still requires ago server notice python
application server entry right there is
nothing like that so
I'm going to show you something still
very new by new I mean I think it was
created maybe two months ago or so it's
still under active development so
um
uh embrace yourself with that
but we're gonna
use it already because you can already
do some interesting things and you know
bugs are going to be fixed anyway uh at
some point so
uh
the new tool is called voicey so it's
just like voila so if you know French
you will know why it's called like this
and it lets you generate those static
dashboards so that you can serve them
statically again like on GitHub pages
and it's all going to be the same as
copyright with a python running in a
browser
so it's only available on Pipi for now
so if you follow on the GitHub repo it's
going to be to be going to be a bit more
tricky because now you're going to use
need to use the voicey CRI to build
the site so you will have to go to the
deploy
GitHub version workflow and update it so
I think there is I put some notes on
that here here so if you are referring
remotely or you want to check that later
check out this notes Here
okay so now that we have what's
installed uh instability build we're
going to do a voicei build
and here I've still specify the other
apps so they are available
as well otherwise it will only be the
generated notebooks for your application
but if we specify the lab and retro apps
via the CRI you will get access to a
to the interfaces like this uh for now
it's just for convenience for us
okay
so
it's still using the output
by default
okay
so here it looks like it didn't generate
the files and I
this is something you can face at some
points if you have an issue with the
files that you think they should be
built but they are not uh it's likely
your cash issue so in that case and I
think I left a note about this
yeah if you encounter any issue and want
to start from scratch you can actually
even delete
the output because it's just generated
right so you can just go back to King
state of your of your repo
and then run the build command again
so we're going to see if that works this
time
yeah okay
hmm
okay maybe not so let's see if I do it
again
okay so we might have an issue here
um
I'm going to let's see
so normally when you build a voicey
yeah okay that was my previous cache
uh you will get a um osc
endpoint here so you can access the kind
of what I like pages in a browser but
here I think we have an issue with the
builds normally
there should be a tree
folder here so maybe let me check if
I can do a more
more cleanup
so I'm going to remove that maybe we
don't need this
otherwise I would just start from a
blank State just to be sure
maybe pass this so sometimes force will
uh
bypass some of the cache steps on by
default build is uh is caching some
files at different steps
just to make sure that you don't do the
same again and again
[Music]
um
okay
looks like it doesn't want to
so
we're going to
do it differently it's the
Gmail got not available today maybe
so the
um
what we can do instead
is I'm going to show you first how you
can configure
your Vesti dashboard so the good thing
is
that
in voila you can confuse for example a
template
and a theme and investor it's also
possible for that you just need to
install the templates
if you want to use a different template
so there is this material template
and if you use it in voila and also
University you'll get something like
this so you can the template is pretty
much just a set of HTML and CSS files
and it will give a different look to
your application that is being built so
for example like this one
um
if you want to know more but it's about
this is based on the ginger true
template system so then you can very you
can do a lot of very Advanced things uh
using that
and then you can also choose a different
theme if you want so for now there are
the light seam and also the Dark theme
but there should be also support for
other Egypt right themes like we saw
before the night theme for example
and they are
things you can control
using this uh
these two CLI Flags so either you pass
the template of the theme
or you can also control it using the
theme query string parameter
and all of this is also possible to put
like we saw before the build time config
file and you can specify them under a
new key here because it's a kind of wire
configuration
and you can specify the theme you want
to use and also
the Dark theme yeah
so
um
what
uh
yes the template is modifying the HTML
of the host page yeah so
if you just export a notebook to HTML
without template is going to be just a
bunch of
sales without the code
on the page but with the template you
can potentially add
more like you can beautify your page
pretty much right if you can add CSS you
can make the page looks pretty you can
add a logo of a company for example if
you want to generate a dashboard at the
very top like this one instead of water
logo you can have a logo of someone else
I think we have time to show this
quickly so
they are defined like that so let's say
what are template
base so this is what the top plate looks
like
can be a bit difficult to grasp but it's
all pretty much just Ginger and if
you've used NP convert it's also using
this system so again here we are into
the Jupiter world where components can
be reused for many different places and
here is a good example of how the NP
converts stack and also the water stack
is being used to generate a static web
page
and as you see CSS and also you have
this idea of blocks that you can inherit
from other templates
um like I said it can be complicated to
to uh to understand it first but uh
the the ginger experts they they know
how to to deal with this uh yeah but uh
hopefully if you want to do something
small it's just a matter of just looking
at one of the existing templates and
then copying and then replacing it with
what you want
uh yeah so a question about the logo
where is it
um
I don't know if it's in this one it
could be
um
is it SVG logo
okay that's just a spinner so yeah
um I don't remember exactly where it is
but it probably is somewhere there
yeah so if you search on the on the
whole code base maybe it would be easier
yeah
right so
now we've seen that so
um I'm going to show you
what we wanted to to make so
this smaller
a small video I mentioned
before
about the app we want we want to make
like the one displaying a map and so on
so
we can remove this
this one and uh we're going to switch
back to the right uh for now so first
I'm going to potentially remove
any
um
any previous
sites that were generated
Okay so
here we're just putting voicing aside
for now
and
um
let's go back to
lab
okay so I'm executing this this says
so we want to make a small application
that
lets users paste a bunch of uis with a
latitude and longitude and we show them
on a map
using IP widgets for the text input and
also the buttons
as usual just shift enter everything
here I pasted an example so it's a bit
faster to to have a look
you can paste it here
and then
click on show
and shows you the photo map this is
again all in the browser except for of
course the images that are fetched from
from the internet you could have them
hosted in somewhere else
then you click on them
and they show up
click on Save I can actually put them
somewhere in the downloads here
save
and then they end up here
and this is pretty much something you
could give to your users like if they
want to create their own gallery or
whatever just make this little app in a
notebook and then expose it they can use
it and they just leave a
home with their map.html file and then
they are happy they could for example
email it to some other people
it's actually also saved in the files
here by default so you can also have a
look at it from here but a jupyter
notebook interface or Jupiter lab
interface like this is
can be a bit complicated to put in front
of users sometimes which is why we have
voila which lets you just take the
notebook and make it as a web app pretty
much
and since I was having issues locally
and there is only 10 minutes left
I'm going to show you the end result so
you have to trust me on this one so here
if you go to deploy I can see show you
what happens
um
it's not the correct one sorry we have
too many too many repos
this is the one so I'm going to post
that on this code afterwards in case you
want just the final thing like
everything configured correctly you can
just look at that it started from the
template as you can see here generated
from the template and it it's pretty
much just the same as what we did
locally I wanted to do it quickly first
just to get an idea of what that means
to build a GPS website but fortunately
yeah that's the one I want to show
deploy was here we have to command to
build the YC app
and that's pretty much what's changed
between
the jupy build and the waste build
that's it
okay and GitHub pages so let's uh this
is deployed on GitHub pages so if I
click on this
uh it's redirecting to lab by default
but here if you choose osce
tree
yeah
we have the material template that the
one is configured to use material
template this is what it looks like when
you choose your
notebook so that's the tree view of your
notebooks and then you click on that
we also set up the Dark theme and then
you see it looks the same as water but
again this is GitHub pages
things there's no server so there is no
Vada running it's just everything
happening in the browser
so while it's uh it can take a while to
load um that's one of the major
drawbacks at the moment yes question
yes yeah so
um
I'm trying to grasp the difference
between 1C
and voila yep
the Jupiter Labs serverless version
using Gita Pages if you want yeah or any
static website or any other static HTTP
server
okay
we were comparing a voila to vasi
uh
okay so let me see a little bit easier
from from here so
or other links
okay so wait first let's finish with
this uh yeah it says what are on the
page but it's not voila it's Versi but
still like water yeah we like to make
things complicated no I'm kidding it's
not true
actually we try to do the opposite but
it's uh it's harder than uh than it
looks so here you can do this uh well it
was also written there so it's the same
as what we had in Notebook but now it's
rendered as an HTML5 so it's a it says
dot HTML here
so that would have been the output I
would have gotten if I had done it
locally as well with the wassce build
but this here is okay on GitHub pages
and I click on show
I'm just going to show
the map
might take a while I think maybe yeah
didn't check I think the Wi-Fi was
pretty good actually so yeah let's see
yeah and you get the same thing here and
uh
I think you can save and save the map
just like we saw before so you can think
of maybe internally at your company you
want to make a static dashboard and it's
very easy to to host you don't want to
put it on kubernetes for example then
you can just do something like this of
course as we saw in the beginning there
are limitations you can't do everything
in the browser at the moment so it's
always a matter of trade-off and the the
use case
to go back to the question first and
then there is another one uh voila uh
what against Westies or to as a reminder
of what is just like jupyter notebook
entrepreneur lab
it needs a python server to run
somewhere so you have to for example
start the ec2 machine or put it on
Heroku or something like that or on your
own server and then it's going to take
requests from this python tornado based
server and run NB convert on the Thrive
to uh generate a dashboard like this one
with wesi it's different it it follows
what the approach of Jupiter light so
it's based on Jupiter light actually and
just extends it everything happens at
build time so this is the difference
you have to first generate your
dashboards at build time that you want
to distribute we'll be looking uh later
on how you can actually do that on the
fly as well I should be possible but
it's not there yet
but everything will be happening at bit
time and you get a set of static files a
set of HTML files and then you can just
take them and host them wherever you
want
yeah
two questions I think there was one
there first maybe uh
yeah unfortunately not and that's what
uh was yeah kind of trying to say just
before it's like you need to do it at
build time so outside of jupiterrite for
now but we'll be looking into being able
to do it inside
Jupiter light in the future yeah which
is
tricky it could be tricky because it has
to happen in a browser if you want to do
this
that means like for now it's based on MP
converts so that means also running NP
convert in a browser it can be tricky so
like over the past three years or so
we've done so many uh pull requests to
change some of the existing packages so
they don't have hard dependencies on
many packages that don't work in a
browser so they can be reused so it's
always this kind of work that needs to
happen first so that you have something
a bit Slimmer that can be used in a
browser so I think in theory it's
possible uh but uh there is nothing like
that at the moment but uh
yeah hopefully soon
yep
yes a python script you mean the python
module yeah yeah so Jupiter light and
also of Westie can read from
the files here so
so if you create a file
actually this python file yeah you can
you can pretty much say my my function
or whatever
and return whatever 42 and then
you can import that module uh from here
or you can yeah
yeah you see that the files you get
there are the ones that correspond to
this and what's he is also aware of that
so there is some kind of file system
mounting happening uh
injectorite so you can the kernels are
aware of the files you create there and
if you add a python module next to your
notebook yeah it will also be available
and you can also import it like this
yeah
fetch yes you can do that you can yeah
everything pretty much happens at the Ci
or at the build time yeah
okay so that was the end result uh if
you go back to the this page at the very
bottom
there are Links of how you can do that
and there is also this template just
like the other one but this one is for
voicey so if you are just interested in
making a voicey app like the last thing
we saw you can just start from that
people directly if you want uh it's
still based on crypto Lite it's very
similar there are just a few things that
change like a mentioned like the CRI and
there is even a screencast that shows
you what it looks like
and you can also use the paradise kernel
so in some situations it would be better
to use a parallel corner at the moment
because you can install packages at
runtime
and maybe some packages are available
there and are not available
[Music]
repos or the only decided to open issues
or discussions and feel free to check
the docs as well and I think we are done
and another question
I think you could use poetry yup you can
well not for the Swiss python kernel
unfortunately it's still really pretty
much based on
on the condo ecosystem
so you could use poetry to manage your
build dependencies and your build
environment but I don't think it's going
to to work in your browser environment
one more yes
[Music]
yeah you can use
the fetch
browser method it's available also in
the python at the python layer and you
can fetch files from
from the internet there are a few
examples in the docs on how to do that
so if you go here working with contents
yeah you can even automate this even
better and you can even okay this is not
about pulling a module directly but you
can even open notebooks directly on the
Fly
using this kind of configuration
there are a bunch of guides there that
show you like different things and if
you think of another use case don't
hesitate to open an issue and we can add
it to the docs or we can document that
so it's a
foreign
yeah you can yeah you I think you can
just fetch them and then you can save
them on disk and I say disk like this
because it's not really disk it's the
virtual fast system in the browser and
then read them from The Notebook yes or
do it at build time like you just fetch
everything at the time and then make
them available via the contents
so the more more differences you add the
bigger we get unfortunately that's the
drawback so here again there's a
difference between paradite and indexes
python kernel the access python kernel
is going to get everything uh when you
start to convert but at least you have
everything ready after in Paradise
they're doing it lazily so the pencils
are fetched when needed so it's also
nice because then you don't download
everything at once yeah so maybe there
will be I hope there will be a
convergence at some point between the
two so that we have the best of both
worlds but for now there is kind of
split like that
so yeah Network traffic can be heavy
still
that's the yeah
yeah like I said yeah the browser might
crash and also there are also other
limitations on the size of the files you
can store so I think it's 15 megabytes
Maybe
something like that I think it depends
maybe on the browsers but like index DB
doesn't let you doesn't allow you to
store something bigger than 50 megabytes
maybe but it's enough if you have small
data but that's the kind of limitations
you can you can hit here so I think we
are out of time thank you all for coming
and if you don't have any if you still
have any questions uh maybe not right
now because I need to jump on another
talk but afterwards you can just find me
no problem yeah
thank you